hey everybody and welcome to a sober
wild ride with stevo man i gotta say
that this week's guest brandon novak has
got to be the most recklessly honest
guest we have ever had i'm asking the
guy about
prostituting himself for drugs and he's
like oh yeah you want to know about
every little
gross sex act he pulled
you just stay tuned okay you stay tuned
right here and where is right here for
me um balls deep in my bucket list to a
baby and you know what that means i
don't have time to go get harassed in
some restaurant no no no no i'm not even
leaving my tour bus at the venue to get
my food and how am i gonna get food like
this delicious tomato soup that's nice
and hot still door dash baby and boy do
i have a deal for you if you want to
knock it off your sofa and just order up
the dopest meal of your choosing plus
get 25 off your first order of 15 or
more and no delivery fees up to a value
of 10 bucks all you gotta do baby is
download the doordash app and use the
promo code stevo that's right they love
the wild ride podcast listeners so and
one more time that's 25
off your first order of 15 or more up to
a value of 10
if you download the door dash app and
use the promo code stevo so enjoy some
door dash beast and let's get into it
okay dude so we're rolling everywhere
i'm okay we're here rolling locks yeah
okay
rolling on everything
see
he's gonna forget about it well
hopefully we can start it there yeah
okay
ladies and gentlemen brandon novak yeah
yeah yeah
i'm really stoked to be here man well
dude we're stoked to have you you know
we didn't make it clear on previous
podcasts that this is actually our tour
bus
it's still a wild ride if anything it's
even wilder
um well if you see this in the
background that's the tour bus right and
you're on said tour
right and i'm so excited that we for the
first time
are sitting down with a guest who has
been present at one of the shows on our
bucket list tour
it's um
and we just got done performing right
now yeah it's
having known you
through a lot of years and a lot of
experiences and and great memories
i never walk away
um feeling like i didn't get what i was
hoping for um when we were getting
loaded it was insanity and and i've been
locked in some hotel rooms with you
where you would not let us leave um
and this was
that but like on angel dust you know
like
i didn't want to
watch it but i couldn't not watch it and
i i found myself like laughing
uncontrollably a lot of times
well thanks dear tonight i i want to
[ __ ] kind of [ __ ] doggo okay
i got like this intimate feeling from
him because he like
really took care of you and and and
comforted you in a really extreme time
right well doggo you want to explain who
doggo is dog was the guy who was
strapped to my back while i was butt
naked and furiously jerking off in the
airplane before i blew the load as i
fell out
with doggo on my back um and
we just it was great to have you at the
show and it was great that that was the
biggest audience i've ever performed
stand up for as a headliner
it's funny because the the last show i
went to uh you were at the smaller
venues comedy club and you have to like
um
order drinks or food right at the table
it's like going to a strip joint you
can't go there and not give money right
it's called a two-drink minimum yeah
which i get but the caveat in that plan
tonight was that i just ate before i got
here and i'm like [ __ ] i don't really
want so when i got here and saw that
that wasn't the deal hey i was really
stoked right then when i saw the crowd
and
i've you know you're a sober guy i'm a
sober guy and you got sober years before
me but i've always watched what you've
done and uh
you've provided me with a lot of like uh
motivation and and kind of
self-assurance in myself through
believing in what you're doing so to see
you transition from those small you know
two drink minimum joints to these
sold out arenas it just continues we're
not an arena but that's the goal yeah we
got to speak it to existence right
thank you dude and we don't have to harp
on about how amazing the performance was
you know we can get into other things
dude there's a lot i want to
talk to you about can i start at the
beginning with you guys when did you
guys meet
what's your timeline together
first time that we met i'm gonna guess
it was um
probably like in the filming of
was it jackass number two that you came
into the scene was it it was two is when
i came to the scene but remember the
gumball rally was that before yeah but i
wasn't on your gun ball rally i don't
think when we went out we destroyed that
car
i feel like that was the first night we
really
hit it off
okay i don't know which came first but
that was a jackass number two situation
yeah so so i guess the filming of wait
were you not on viva la bam yeah you
weren't there yeah you were totally yeah
all right well i think that the first
time i remember would have been uh like
the day when they brought like a snow
blower into like april's house and it
was like ski down the stairs that's that
that you're right that was the first
initial meeting and dude it's your
[ __ ] fault dude that i got that uh
awful baby tattoo because
i remember the [ __ ] fall because that
day when they filled the house with snow
and you went skiing down the stairs and
flew through the screen door it was that
same day and i think was the first day
that we met when i saw your
your tattoo of two
male rollerblades the
rollerbladers like having missionary
gay sex
and it was i was just like dude that is
the most aggressive i remember yeah like
hilarious tattoo
and then like you were
i was like i gotta one-up that
and i remember when that was like my
motivation
and you did
you did you did it and then people were
like he did
like stephen we love you we're your fan
but
yeah
cause you were like you were writing a
book at the time you're like i'm going
to use that for the cover of my book
oh i don't know that i was writing a
book you had some kind of book i was
always working on a book but
um but it was never like a real serious
thing until after i got sober but
nonetheless like you were [ __ ]
steps and eons ahead of me as far as
like the fame with jackass so i was just
taking it vicariously through you
wanting my tattoo on your book like i'll
[ __ ] ride that coattail let's do it
yeah dude and uh i mean suffice to say
you were a mess you know i mean you
haven't been like very open about your
struggles with with uh with drugs and
alcohol i thought maybe we could kind of
peer into this
so so you are super candid about it and
um like as somebody who follows you on
social media
like it seems that that um
like all the time you're posting hey if
you need help like with with your issues
with addiction yeah then call me yeah
and you include a phone number there is
that actually your number in your pocket
like it would be ringing all day so i
have two phones that i carry around one
is that number and if i don't answer
that like if it doesn't work with what
i'm doing like right now then it goes
through to a team of people that help
aid and assist that person with whatever
their situation is okay what's the
success rate if somebody calling you and
getting help and staying sober i mean
not that there's a percentage but is it
common i mean do people actually go
through on yeah totally you know what's
it's you have to weed it out it's i mean
scott
knows better than like everything
success rates in general with addiction
are like they're just terrible yeah it
makes it very undesirable if you look at
the stats like you just think you're
fighting unwinning calls yeah that's how
i felt when i first heard the statistics
and i was in rehab in 1995 and i was
only 20 years old and i was like wait 95
percent of the alcoholics don't get
sober like then why would i even bother
and the statistics kept me loaded
totally but then once i was ready yeah i
could argue that the statistics kept me
sober because i knew that the odds were
so against me that i had to just like do
everything in my power to give myself an
advantage and and it really like made me
take it seriously and so i stayed in
sober living until i had two years i did
all this stuff to like
really give myself the advantage and and
that's
you know really why i'm still around
that's my [ __ ] approach exactly like
you know obviously
i i i [ __ ] i loved drugs and alcohol
i couldn't get enough right dude let's
not say that in the past tense right i
mean [ __ ] dude
yeah i would love to get it but now it's
like i i get off on like the sobriety
part of it right it's the kind of the
closest connection that i have with that
past so it works for me so me i like you
i remember going to treatment like this
half of the room's dead this is half of
the room look to your right your left
two of those are dead i'm like right now
they think they're going to say they
said okay look around there's 12 of you
only one of you is going to make it
that's like that's what the statistics
are dude why am i wasting your time
[ __ ] get loaded and i do that and so
when i got sober i'm like dude [ __ ]
statistics because the statistics state
that i should be higher dead right now
and i'm not and it defies odds and
logics so like if i can do it why the
[ __ ] can't you right i think that
the problem is that the statistics are
for like alcoholics and
addicts at large whereas like when
people actually
get serious about recovery and start
doing the things that we do then all of
a sudden the statistics are a whole
different deal yeah yeah they don't even
exist really yeah if you
get into this program of recovery and do
the things we do
then it's a pretty simple process yeah
but let me ask you this because it's
something that that uh occurs to me
kind of a lot you know being someone who
follows you like
how just about every post that you put
on instagram like it almost invariably
is related to your recovery yeah and
then and and so i think my question is
how
many people
have expressed concern
that like whoa you know like you're
putting it out there so much that like
we worry about you sure
some have right like the people that are
pretty close to me have
because i because i identify as one of
those people i i think man
like
novak's putting it out there so much
like as like his identity yeah that like
it feels like you know i'm like scared
like i just worry about it well
thank you for that right like that that
that's what friends are for yeah i do um
and for me i kind of treat it as like an
added layer of safety right like i'm
such an extremist and i'm such a [ __ ]
all or nothing that it kind of adds a
little more to like
the
what helps keep me like wanting to do
this like i could easily sneak and let
myself down and no one will know so it's
like jumping out of a plane with two
parachutes as opposed to one if that
makes any sense i mean i just think like
here's what creeps me out and it creeps
me out so much
when i heard that
um
the people
with the highest rates of relapse are
people who work in recovery yeah i mean
it's so counterintuitive if you imagined
that like
like you know the people who died of
cancer the most were doctors who worked
with cancer patients it's like
you should know right right it's it's
counterintuitive absolutely terrible
example with the cancer thing but um but
it just makes me like think you know
like i want to be so careful to not ever
like professionalize yeah require to let
that become the identity of the industry
right dude i had this one experience
where uh
what like i i got i got uh hired
to go um to a university and they did
i was to just do an on-stage q a about
mental health and i didn't even think
about either paying me like you know an
obnoxious amount of money to go out and
like answer questions i'd go on stage
and like
and and very quickly every question that
they asked me about mental health my
answer i would find was like oh well you
know i kind of only really know like
like addictions i can't speak to
you know like like all the various
mental health issues but like you know i
see everything kind of through the prism
of of just like you know addiction and
alcoholism and recovery and then like
very quickly i realized oh my god like
i'm here getting paid to share the
message of recovery and the scariest
thing of all was after i got done i i
had this thought flash through my mind
which was
oh well dude if everything dries up and
comedy doesn't work out and like this or
that like i mean i suppose i could go
around getting paid to talk about
recovery and then i was like
no
you know i'm like that's that's what
scares me the most sure i
you know the two things that i know
about in this world uh
is skateboarding and and drugs and
alcohol like that's kind of what i i
know and i love the most and dude by the
way you are [ __ ] skateboarding dude
i'm so impressed by the the
video you showed me before
again and i'm not trying to suck you off
live on this show but
seeing the clips that you send me and
i'm like dude this is because when i got
sober i wanted no part of skateboarding
because i felt like it was the love that
i let get away have you surpassed a
younger you yeah i'm
excited that's been my goal like like in
my i was like man in my 40s if i can out
skate every younger version of me that's
yeah that's i mean i have a video part
coming out that is by far the best part
i've ever put out at 42. right right i'm
still learning tricks um i'm in the best
shape i've ever been in like physically
but we have to fight so hard to get a
trick i saw your post the other day when
you slammed like a kick flip
i could relate to like i saw in your
face i'm so sure yeah
i need a walker for like five days after
i skate
it's not it's tough
it's a lot i can't flip the board much
these days
um
steve have you surpassed the old school
yeah
i
there are certain things that i just
will never be able to do again that i
could do at a certain time you know
but
what i've been going after and like when
i try to get a new trick it's such a
battle but the tricks that i have gotten
are things that i either have never done
before or are like way bigger versions
of something i've done before so like i
i have outskated myself but
leaving out a bunch of stuff that i
could never do that i could do before i
noticed that i i i start really um
kind of talking myself out of things
that i could probably do like oh well
it's pretty dicey i could get hurt where
before that was never the mind frame it
was like
do first think last now i'm kind of
being really cautious overly maybe
mm-hmm
[Laughter]
every time in your life
that is on the podcast okay but hey he's
counting so dude
like
here's another question when you were
in the throes of addiction you know
actively shooting up as much as he
possibly could yeah
like how did you not get like aids and
[ __ ] were you like sharing needles and
should you just get super lucky
man how do you not get aids when you're
sharing needles is that a question or
what plus brandon novak has no problem
telling you exactly what the answer is
and i got no problem telling you how i
don't get sick on tour because i take
care of my hydration man and my vitamins
and how do i do that with liquid iv this
doesn't just make you more hydrated and
healthier it tastes absolutely delicious
i got all these killer flavors you know
what i'm going for today
strawberry baby and so i just take one
stick a little packet of liquid iv
drop it into 16 ounces of water and boom
it's like i drank
three 16 ounces of water
that's what i'm talking about man and
convenient 16 ounce can of liquid death
makes it really easy to just drop that
all in there
this is how i start my day man and with
extra hydration extra vitamins i don't
worry about getting sick because i can't
be missing shows on my tour hell no
all right so if you go to liquid
iv.com and use the promo code stevo you
get 25 off of anything you want to get
and trust me you want to get it so to
get that 25
off of anything you want to order at
liquidity.com
use the promo code stevo baby and never
miss a show never get sick and keep
rocking on tour yeah dude
now let's talk about not getting aids
my newest book that came out there's a
chapter called the aids needle that i
shot up with
and like
things got really bad i'm living in
these abandoned houses in east baltimore
and i remember i was doing my deal and
the needle uh jammed up right and it's
like the middle of the night and it's
so i'm
look on this floor and it's just
polluted with all these dirty needles
used needles and i literally
kind of process of elimination looked
for the one that was the least used like
this one doesn't have a's on this one
does this one does
this one probably out of all of them
might not like this is my best shot of
it no like don't you give yourself a
pretty good chance if you just flush it
through with water
bleach
blade okay but even water would help
right because what it is about
hypodermic needles that makes it so uh
dangerous for hiv is that in that hollow
needle in there it the the hiv virus is
not exposed to air like on a tattoo
needle it's a solid needle so
everything's exposed to air it's very
difficult to get aids from that
at that point in time my life i had no
idea of any of that knowledge that
wasn't my
reference you know it was just flush
through i'm just like sick let's let's
do it
right and um
and i i use the needle and
you're making it sound like it was one
night you're telling me you never should
know i did but this is the one time
where like i thought like i i definitely
just got it right like it was one time
that was really stuck out above all the
other times that i've shared needles
right and uh and i've done it often at
that point in time so
a few months later on the line i'm sick
and there's this place it's kind of like
a health clinic and they're paying you
uh thirty dollars to get blood work done
so they pay you 30 to get the blood work
done and then they give you 10 or then
no i'm sorry they give you 20 to come
back and pick the results up so
it's a medical study and they're testing
like different ways of uh they want the
drug addicts to come in a to get tested
so they know they'll do that with the
money and then the 20 on the back end to
pick it up to get the
the results so when you come in they're
also giving you clean needles clean
because they're it's kind of a
harm reduction deal right and and uh i
think there's a great many addicts that
just don't want to know if they have hiv
or not and so that's they give they're
really paying you 20 bucks to inform you
because should the addict know that they
have hiv then maybe they'll be a little
bit more responsible about spreading it
ignorance is no longer bliss right point
proven so i i get i go 30 bucks let him
take a test cool no no intentions ever
to go back and get the results because
i'm [ __ ] you're like dude i don't
need 20 bucks that bad no i'm living in
a dumpster but
until one day i needed the 20 bucks that
bad right so i go back were you so
scared terrified and they they they give
me the 20 and the doctors and i said
look doctor please i beg you
just don't tell me if i have hiv you can
tell me anything else just give me it
all but that
and he says
well the good news is you don't have hiv
but the bad news is you have hepatitis c
and i [ __ ] high-fived him
he's like what the [ __ ]
oh yeah i remember when uh
like i had my family all like um giving
me a hard time about my lifestyle and my
addiction and i was like look i'm gonna
go to this [ __ ] uh executive health
program like uh and get the most
comprehensive check out known to man
because dr drew told me about it wasn't
even covered by insurance because it was
just so like extra yeah i'm like i'm
gonna get tested every [ __ ] test you
can possibly if i come back healthy then
you guys get off my back and i was just
like dude of course i'm going to come up
clean so i go i go up uh get all these
tests and then the doctor calls like hey
i need to give you your results in
person oh that's like that's a horrible
sign so i go in there and i'm thinking
[ __ ] man like what what what is like
what's wrong with my word i'm scared for
you right now i go into the doctor's
office and i'm like doc
is it my wiener
you know
is it like is it like i'm thinking like
i've got some terrible std he goes no
your wiener's fine and i'm like whoa
and uh he says oh no it's your heart he
says you've got a heart condition he's
you've got the heart of an
80 year old man oh wow i don't see you
living to the age of like 40 or
something like that and i was like who
that high five yeah right
[ __ ] my heart my wiener is cool
i'll [ __ ] my way into heaven yeah and
then it turned out that uh that i would
like i had very like borderline
cardiomyopathy like
minor
so did you do it
you're good
i think my heart's good dude hey how do
you get into shooting dope i mean i know
it's obvious like did you start with
viking and you went to oxy and then
you're like [ __ ] it's just cheaper to
get heroin or like what's the psychology
because not a lot of people but not a
lot of people decide to inject in their
vein like what was that decision like
the first time injecting into your veins
so no i didn't start with the pills it
kind of went from you know the herb to
the blow
to i sold i did grateful dead tour for a
little bit
wait what year uh
96 95 95. jerry died in 95. yeah well i
was supposed to be no yeah because i was
supposed to be at the last show they
played unbroken chain at at charlotte
coliseum which is where i got arrested
so i didn't get to see him play the song
so
definitely 95 because i was at that show
and before my reference of years is
[ __ ] but
that was the first time i was arrested
at 17 and in mecklenburg i ended up
going to mecklenburg state penitentiary
because you're an adult at 17 from the
[ __ ] grateful dead show but point
being is when i got into dead tour i got
into it for selling drugs and like
making good money not sure for the music
me too man i went to every single show
on the east coast 94 tours of the
grateful dead what kind of drugs are you
guys
probably
maybe then but a little right after so i
might have just missed you i mean dude i
would show up to the show
like with my car on fumes you know yeah
i had it i had this used car it'd be on
fumes and i would like go like do a
backflip for like you know like a buck
or something like five backflips for a
dollar and then i was like okay cool
like i've got five bucks and then i
would like
for five bucks i would go to a dead head
and get like three hits of assets yeah
and then i would take each hit of acid
and go sell them for five bucks now i've
got 15 bucks and then i would take that
15 bucks and go buy like an eighth of a
week that's it and then like once i ate
the wheat i would sell that for like
[ __ ] 30 bucks and now i got 30 bucks
and i go and [ __ ] buy a bag of
mushrooms it's just a constant come up
so i was riding for pal at the time and
i would go and i'd have boxes of boards
and i'm just selling boards on the lot
trading them for tickets no you name it
yeah and so you're a fan of grateful
dead music yeah i love it i know that i
listen to it more now with my age i'm
just kind of at that point
i love it dude
i've kind of come back i missed the
whole fish era that didn't really do it
for me because i did dead tour so i was
like yeah not my but anyway so i'm
i meet up with this guy
out of san francisco who who lays
uh grams of acid lays crystal grams so
we're getting like 20
10 packs at a time books 10 packs of
sheets of water assets so that's how
that hits
like a sheet has a hundred years this is
a thousand in a book
okay so i'm getting like this guy's
coming with the raw gram and he's
actually laying it in a hotel and me and
a couple other dead you know we go in
and
i get this paper one night and the guy
who's gonna buy a few books doesn't have
all the cash but he has some heroin how
much would a book be for me at that at
that level where i was getting it right
from the guy in the grams like three
four hundred bucks and then how much can
you make up that for a thousand thousand
hits and this is back in 95.
a thousand hits or five bucks a hit
that's 5 000 to your turn to see more
than 10 times in your money easily but i
wasn't doing that i was still selling it
in books for like 800
and still doing great because we had so
much if you get caught with a book
just in its wake just
people in prison for decades yeah it was
gnarly how do you know that your
documentary i don't know if it was a
documentary but we're just friends you
know facts it's [ __ ] it's
widely known i didn't care about
overthrowing the government but i know
that like like a lot of acid if you've
got lsd that's a [ __ ]
heavy crime it's serious how long do you
go to jail for if you get caught
overthrowing the government
i don't know
bro i'm starting the government but
is it because it's like beheaded it's
like you can brainwash people to or
something like that
but we still didn't get to the heroine
yeah
so i sold this guy
to the back of the hair
and the heroine and if you didn't know
and here we go
if you need help call me
um i i i i if you're buying books
yeah
we have a guy flying in from san
francisco who's laying raw grams and and
that leaves us with lots of books and uh
one night this guy was short on the cash
so he gave us some heroin
and i was like cool whatever paid no
mind to it what kind of heroin tar no
yeah he flew in from san francisco we
were in baltimore so it was like just
white raw dope not like the west coast
chiva tar
and i just put it in my sock drawer like
totally didn't think about it forgot
about it
a few days later we're catching the
greyhound bus to i forget what show it
was we were jumping back on tour
and my buddy's like you got the dope and
i'm like oh yeah cool so
in my mother's bedroom at my mother's
house at
six just turned 17. how much job was it
it was like 200 bucks worth okay so
what's that like uh
maybe like a
a gram it was raw heroin so you don't
get a lot there um but we did it and i
instead
snored it and instantly threw up so that
continued on
but how i went from that to shooting it
was well because snorting it's just
[ __ ] wasteful did you like it when
you started it yeah i loved it yeah but
you you build a tolerance yeah right and
you need more and you gotta spend more
and spend more to to get that same high
and starting like everybody does harem
for their first time they're like i
would never never shoot up but then
you're snorting it or smoking it and
like you develop a tolerance it's not
getting away and you're like [ __ ] man
like and then i'm heroin and i just like
i can't not shoot up because it's just
not economical and i want to actually
get that feeling stronger and then
someone like me comes along and says
dude if you [ __ ] shoot up like a half
of a dime bag you'll be just as high as
sniffing that 300 and you know what i
mean and so all of a sudden shooting up
is not so taboo anymore did you ever
shoot anybody up for their very first
time no i wasn't good at i could do me
but how do you learn how to shoot up
i got some words of wisdom for you
don't shoot up how about that yeah and
you want some real wisdom let me tell
you the saying i heard
the only beverage of the wise man is
water and you can get your water in a
super cool looking tall boy can that
looks just like a beer and is infinitely
recyclable from liquid death telling you
ma'am it's the easiest way to stop
drinking a bunch of super unhealthy soda
to switch to liquid death sparkling
water and you're not just making a
healthy choice for yourself you're
making a healthy choice for mother earth
man because the environment is getting
devastated by plastic which is why
infinitely recyclable cans from liquid
death are saving the world and i'm
telling you man i'm a lot healthier
because i'm drinking a lot more water
staying hydrated in the mornings with my
liquid death spring water and drinking
my liquid death sparkling water
throughout the day now you want to know
how cool this company is they're giving
you the craziest deal you go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo and you get free shipping on all
your orders of water and merch and
they've got killer merch
do you know how crazy that is like cases
of water they weigh a lot to ship them
that's expensive and you don't have to
pay it if you go to liquiddeth.como
you get free shipping on your orders man
that's because liquid death is a cool
company and they love the listeners of
the wild ride podcast so get on over to
liquiddeth.com stevo and
let's talk about how you learn how to
shoot out shoot up
like i know a buddy of mine who was in
there and watched a youtube video
i i was [ __ ] advanced like i didn't
do that yeah i just i i would give
someone a little bit
can you look up on youtube how to shoot
up heroin and up a video
that's insane how do i use a needle yeah
how to so that but how do you who
teaches you that so i would give
somebody a little bit to do it for me at
first what a [ __ ] and then oh
absolutely and then after i got tired of
giving it to him i learned real quick
let me do your piece of [ __ ] if you if
you shoot somebody up for the first time
yeah but i mean you you are but you're
already so disconnected from reality
that like why would that not make sense
yes
no there's no ethics and morals involved
of like
when you're
smacked up at that point were you ever
in a situation where someone od'd and
everyone's like let's dip
or like throw them in a dumpster no no
even at that point i don't know if i
would it happens right yeah
no i i'd like to think of myself as a
[ __ ] junkie with morals like i i
actually was like
i think a good person here hold on to
this hundred for me yeah i would [ __ ]
steal that
but i wouldn't let you die
right did you find anything
oh my god so this video is
safer
heroin injecting
how to do it the safest way possible it
started he was like washing his hands at
the beginning there you go
thousand views
and how long
what how long is the video three minutes
you know uh okay yeah how many months
has it been out or sorry it's it's eight
years it's been out so maybe it's the
video your buddy saw it could be
wow
so when you're shooting up like what are
you you're flicking it to get the
bubbles out because you'll die if a
bubble gets into your veins they would
say that an air bubble could create
something in your veins
you know i just did it because that's
just what i saw other people doing yeah
and i didn't want to like
yeah i wasn't reinventing the wheel here
and the first time you get shot up with
it you're just like oh dear god so the
first time i got shot up with though was
not that way right so i'm sniffing him
sniffing it and then my girlfriend at
the time for driving through this
reservoir and she nods out and my head
and gets a car accident and my head goes
through the windshield right so i'm in
the hospital and they have me with all
these ivs um and a guy brings me heroin
to the room and he just puts it right
into the iv that then goes in my arms so
did he have to cook it on a spoon
yeah totally in the hospital room and
then that was my first
you know way of injecting it oh yeah did
you like it i loved it so do you know
when
in the hood
when addicts get really bad and they
kind of blow out of their veins and they
have to go to the hospital and the
hospital puts an iv in
they'll leave with the iv just because
they have a direct main line yeah
because they can't hit it on their own
holy moly right you don't want to close
that door
so they'll like legit go there to get
them to run an iv on you for whatever
they say they need or however they can
make it happen and then
walk out of the hospital with the
[ __ ]
bag
how long
is that good for how long can you keep
it i don't know these still falls out
yeah i'm
sure did you ever have abscesses
is there is there a point where like uh
a rock bottom of like [ __ ] dude i'm
shooting up in my toes now or am i
shooting shut up bleach one time
that was pretty bad you rejected bleach
yeah because so i'm living with this
this woman named annette and these
projects that i no way people really
belong in it's uh and i couldn't leave
the house to go cop right it was like a
really rough neighborhood and uh so she
would go but one day i didn't have any
money so she goes out the cop and when
she leaves i get her her needles and her
spoons and i'm like
putting water on the spoons and getting
like her leftovers like a hot shot of
her leftovers but i'm also using her
needle scraping the resin yeah so you're
like i'm shooting up her blood so i
should probably make some bleach into it
but there's a little bit of hair running
but i'm in a hurry right i'm in a hurry
because the net's gone so time is of the
essence because if she comes back and
catches me in her [ __ ] she's gonna [ __ ]
me up so i'm like i have a thing of
water and a thing of bleach you don't
[ __ ] with it nothing of blood and the
hair
so i'm rushing to i get the
water clean out and then the bleach i'm
i'm hurrying up and pushing it through
and then i intend to put the needle in
the water to then put on the res but i'm
in such a hurry i put the bleach on the
res and i cook it and when it comes back
it has a yellow tint just like heroin
does anyways bleach yeah so i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i have a great shot here like
i'm going to actually get high off this
and i put it in me and it's and i
probably maybe like five cc's so it's
not much it's like
and about two in
i feel like an
internal inferno that is like but i'm in
such denial that it's not heroin i still
continue to put it in because like i
can't believe that wow dude and at the
time i have warrants for my arrest
so although i realize i just shot up
this bleach i cannot call 9-1-1 because
i'll go to jail so i just sit in the
corner and just dump water over my head
over and over because you're on fire
yeah
man so you're telling me that like if
that you
you can shoot up bleach and you're okay
yeah i didn't i'm here five cc's five cc
wow
so it's about that much but it was it
was probably wow dude does any part of
you want to be like dude i'm going to
film a gnarly stunt hey everybody this
is i'm brandon novak and this is
shooting up bleach absolutely
does anybody watch
you're not going to do it
because there was a joke that's like you
can get rid of covid by like taking blue
shield
if you get covered yeah try to try it
everybody try and try to bleach what
happens
well it didn't cure me of the [ __ ]
hepatitis i had so i don't know i would
like to do the bleach okay
well they have pills now that gets rid
of it so check this out so i i i
continue going i go to a doctor
right when there's a pill called harvoni
that had just hit the market it hadn't
even it was clear by the fda but
insurance companies like didn't know
what to do with it it was right in that
weird window of time of like everyone
just didn't know it was a cure for
hepatitis c
go to the doctor
and the doctor's assistant had read my
book because dream seller had already
been out this was the first book the
first i got some yeah yeah rightfully so
what the [ __ ] wrong with you we're on
the set of jackass 3d and he's all
[ __ ] up but his book just came out and
i actually like gave it an effort to
read the book and like and in the book
he describes like
addiction like the whole situation like
recovery like what it's about like he's
just like i was like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] has a complete
understanding
of like what the disease is like what
it's like and he's describing like but
he's just loaded and wasted i was like i
was just so [ __ ] frustrated and
offended by it because i was like a
couple years sober at that time and i'm
like dude how do you write this book
that like eloquently describes recovery
and you're just [ __ ] her oh you said
that's a piece of [ __ ] yeah and what did
you say you remember that i don't even
remember the conversation
because i wasn't offended that much
i didn't lose sleep
damn but so yeah that's the thing i was
too smart for my own [ __ ] good yeah
so anytime that i found myself in a
position where i could potentially save
my life i'd out-think myself out of it
every time i dumb my way into sobriety
this time if you didn't know i'm sober
so you're shooting dope for it's like a
decade at least oh [ __ ] yeah wow yeah
how long were you shooting before oxy
became yeah that one yeah i so i did
heroin first and then backtracked to the
pills oh really because then like you
know i started ending up on like
jackass and people of bam and i got like
some recognition and
like like doc man like i'm [ __ ] i
heard broke this hurt that like oh no
problem you know and i get the pills
then what's what's the worst detox oxy
or heroin uh i
sh they're both kind of one in the same
it wasn't you know
it was it all sucked it's like what gets
you more stone hash or weed yeah
great analogy what about methadone
that's the [ __ ] worst liquid i was
scared to do that i tried to shoot that
one that's the box fired yeah i do that
in detox i tried to shoot that ones too
that was [ __ ] [ __ ] horrible yeah
dude it's all bad news
you're talking about viva la bam and
jackass yeah so
how much in contact are you with bam
these days
not much at
all is good out to him like a week ago
or two weeks ago and and there was the
first time i didn't i actually didn't
hear back which is a good thing yeah
right now knowing where he's at in the
position he's in no news is good news
and and i know uh
that he was at a position
in his journey with his recovery that uh
he could have a phone briefly he kind of
earned that and then i think he's
allowed to have a phone right now and
he's just choosing to not use it which
is the best [ __ ] sign i wish that was
the case okay
that would you're right it's like [ __ ]
there's a sign of hope here is he out
and about or is he interesting so he
they he had the phone and because he
wasn't doing what should be done they
took the phone back from him got it so
that's why
yeah totally all right yeah so yeah he's
in a program um and
the good thing is now is is uh he's got
like he's under a conservatorship you
know and it's not a conservative ship
it's a guardianship oh really the
conservatorship britney spears
has financial implications with the
conservatorship they're they're in
charge of all of your your money and
everything a guardianship
they kind of leave your money out of it
yeah and uh and the guardianship they're
just like kind of
there's rules you have to abide by and
he's like forced to be and how how long
do you have to be like that for i think
that i mean i don't know if we're really
even allowed to talk about about it too
much but um
as i understand it it's like uh
still happening yeah yeah really we'll
leave it at that
and the good thing is is
it it's kind of doing for him what he
can't do for himself
right i know i agree i agree very much
and um you know i it like even bringing
up bam is just like a
lightning rod of uh
you know like controversy and [ __ ] it
really is
it's a shame what i want to say is that
i and i've said this before but i'll say
it again is that i've always
not always i used to always
be so jealous of him he was such a
[ __ ]
just ambitious [ __ ] like
just talented
like
he was so good at making footage so
funny and like naughty just making great
amazing footage out of like nothing even
happening and i was like man for me to
get footage i got to like
do something huge you know like i
couldn't just make footage out of
nothing like that all you had to do was
get a [ __ ] dog
idiot that's right
i know but like and i would always say
bam's younger than me he's richer than
me he's like he's better looking than me
he's more talented than me like you know
like and all of that was true
and um
i just i i
now with everything going on like i wish
that
we could have the band back who i was
always so jealous of i i would love
to
be jealous of him again and and and i
want that for him i want isn't it crazy
how the world works and kind of goes
full circle you know how you would now
give anything to have that guy back that
at one point in time you're very jealous
of well yeah i mean
i see what you're saying but it's right
and when i say jealous i think that the
that's just my natural
reaction to being impressed by somebody
you know like when i go to the circus
i'm [ __ ]
jealous of the performers because i want
to be that rad one and and that's why
you are that rad dude this is [ __ ]
stevo's wild ride tour here [ __ ]
[ __ ] come and i'm sober
but no i
i have credit he's my best friend in the
world um if it wasn't for him i'd be
buried in that plot that my mother
bought me in baltimore like he was the
one that that stopped what he was doing
and reached out to me and said yo
come to westchester live with me like
skate again and wasn't that like a super
misguided exercise in enabling you in
the in the big picture and he brought
you like
he brought you the enough fame and
recognition for you to just
keep staying sick but i don't believe
that he could comprehend right of course
what was going on of course he thought
he was helping you but he was doing
knowing what i know now yes it was like
a terrible recipe for [ __ ] disaster
right and you were just this weird
whipping boy for him
but if you look at this if you weigh out
the scales of justice it's it's that in
that world or like being homeless
shooting up bleach in baltimore
so it's like
right
and and then he had at his house like a
garage that was just filled with like
bam skateboards and you would just go
and oh yeah go for that yeah
like like when you're on dead tour
except
that it was it wasn't mine
wasn't sending me those boards yeah
right and and it wasn't dead to her it
was the the crack house yeah how much
did you like crack i didn't i was scared
oh i was i had enough common sense to be
scared because like
people would offer me hits and i would
take them far few in between but i could
barely come up with 10 bucks a day
sometimes let alone like every 20
minutes so i knew i didn't need to like
embark
with meth like i was like really weirded
out by it but i never turned it down
like in the early days like when i lived
in albuquerque and like albuquerque is a
place for that 97.98 when in rome like
uh
and it was just like weird biker myth
there wasn't it was like old school meth
where if you snorted a line it just it
was like you snorted broken glass it was
so gnarly burns you want to cut your
nose off before it was like the thing
yeah right
and then uh and then there was a lot of
smoking meth out of light bulbs and [ __ ]
yeah like uh
but i never really
was too injured i mean it was always
like like sure but
so yeah what else what other like
[ __ ] salacious [ __ ] do we want to ask
okay i've got i've got one like talk to
me about like [ __ ]
like prostituting yourself for drugs is
it true that you did like crazy [ __ ]
like weird gay stuff that and you're not
gay i would let men blow me i would
never blow the men okay right um there
was standards there
yeah is this in your book yeah it's how
my first book starts at the very first
chapter yeah yeah so you're okay with
just going hard in the paint on this one
right here
it's like a monday morning yeah
yeah i felt pretty comfortable asking
that question yes brandon's an open book
yeah yeah totally totally if i'm not
i'll just not answer it right um but
yeah uh
so it got to a point where you know you
said it tonight um you know
with your
loves you're in this amazing
relationship and she says hey we're in a
relationship but you say it better than
i i'll [ __ ] this up but
intimate you don't need to show your
body to everybody right and you're like
but everything's a million times funnier
if i'm naked right right so
so for me i had did so many things
in addiction right like the prostitution
parts to then like
you know my character on viva la van was
nudie novak so it was just naked
everywhere and then like we were doing
the [ __ ] face unstoppable tour which was
bam's band yeah and i remember doing
this interview in australia and and the
interviewer said
we hear that there's like some
homosexual tendencies that take place on
stage
are you a homosexual and i'm like are
you calling me
gay and and i don't give a [ __ ] and and
and i'm like you calling me gay and i
push him down and i pull his pants down
and like bam a couple holding down and i
pull his dick out and i do two pumps
just to prove that i wasn't gay
and i left the [ __ ] interview you
know so i did all this weird [ __ ] and
and this is how i realized that i wasn't
gay and i love gay people at some point
because you you did two pumps yeah i got
his dick in your mouth just to prove
that it was just enjoy it
right there
that was that wasn't my thing that well
here's where i realized it wasn't my
thing later on down the road i end up in
this recovery house
and i want to like jerk off one day and
dude that's a serious crime to like
physically like push everyday
what year was that
[ __ ] everything's kind of a blur during
those years probably s
statute of limitations
whatever it needs to be that's how long
it will be exactly right
okay so so you let guys suck your dick
but you never sucked anyone else's dick
unless they called you gay
yeah
yeah yeah but would you jerk guys off no
it was never like a thing like that's
not really what they were looking for
for some reason that's the thing in that
world you let guys suck your dick but
what if they wanted to eat your ass i
used to i used to live with this guy
would that be like more
um i would negotiate totally but i used
to let i used to let a guy shave my
[ __ ] he just wanted to shave it for
how much uh like 20 40 bucks i lived
with him 20 40 bucks whatever he had
yeah
just shave it
interesting
you have to grow it out for him to pay
you again
i wasn't really a health and wellness
kind of guy at that point so when he was
ready i dropped trout like
it wasn't anything great going on but so
i ended up in this recovery house
and this is back when vcrs are in play
and right and uh i want to jerk off and
there's these two guys
brian and donovan who are like
openly flamboyantly gay guys and they're
amazing guys
but i'm looking all through the house
for a porn can't find one and in brian's
room he's not there
there's a porn in the vcr and i press
play and it's a gay porn and i'm like
you know what this is a perfect time for
me to answer the [ __ ] inevitable
question am i gay and i watched the porn
with a complete open mind to see if i
got a hard [ __ ] and i didn't
so i i think that kind of answered the
question but did you try i i wasn't
opposed to it you know like i was she
did try yeah totally i mean
i like held my dick kind of like plate
caressed it you know danced with it a
little bit all right
on the date it didn't react
[Laughter]
i also have uh
i have a guy's come in me
but it's i've never been [ __ ]
it's like kind of like that magic trick
where you do where you get on your back
and you drink the thing with your feet
right right so me and bam were like up
doing blow for like five days straight
and after like day three delusional
paranoid [ __ ] gets weird so
5 a.m probably fourth or fifth day in
out of our minds hadn't slept a minute
we're shooting a game of pool
and we have one of our tattoo artists
there with us
i win the game of pool
we then go into the bedroom i lay on the
bed
ben puts a pillow over my head he pulls
a laptop out and puts porn on
and jerks off and comes onto my arm
and then we bring the tattoo artist in
and he traces around it and then without
no ink on it he then puts the [ __ ] into
my arm
see that right there
in me that's the room never [ __ ] in me
you know what i mean
wow
i've never heard of that before yeah
that's an npd right there they got blood
brothers
yeah but the whole thing is just so
wrong that it's kind of right
yeah i i wanted to give you guys not
even that wrong yeah you know you won
i used to try and shut up like bet
people 100 bucks they could guess what
it was and then one time i was in the
airport and the
the bartender
who was a a pretty openly gay guy i'm
like yo if you can guess this i'll give
you a hundred bucks he goes oh honey
that's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
one glass of wine i had to tip 100 bucks
on cause i only had a card i'm like dude
that's it that's something
yeah dude that's epic man yeah i i love
that you're uh
that you're so candid and transparent
dude it's
why not man right dude i [ __ ] dig
that and and um to be clear i really
hope that uh that i wasn't disrespectful
in any other it wasn't my intention to
be dude
i know that it would never be right like
i know you and i know kind of i know
what your sobriety is like and i know
that you're way past that point of like
trying to pull like out of left field
thing sure i'm not out to make anybody
feel bad i'm not out to like you know i
know that to to harm anybody but at the
same time i also like just
don't know how to have a filter and so
if i'm curious about something i'm just
gonna
dude there was one point where i was
like i was switching sponsors i'm like
you know what maybe i'll ask stevo to be
my sponsor and and my next thought was
like dude he's way too sober i'm like
too nervous to you know what i mean oh
yeah because because i know how like
transparent how authentic and how how
much you work this and i don't know if i
wanted to like level up that much
um
leveling up it's like you don't want
your friends to sponsor yeah you don't
want to you don't want to have like a
relationship you know that would be to
tangle the wires a little bit okay i
would say that uh i learned immensely
from you you know well right now i i
really pay close attention to what you
do from a [ __ ] idea
there was a point and we won't say what
it was but a point when you called me up
for advice like pretty recently yeah and
uh
i and and you know
it it impressed me and it helped me
really like yeah you know that when
people reach out for for help that
you're actually helping the person who
you reach out to a helps b helps aid the
most kind of deal yeah and uh
you know and i was just i was impressed
and uh
and and it meant a lot to me to to help
you kind of
navigate that situation that you found
yourself in and it was heavy and i
wouldn't just call anybody so like to
share something with you sure so for you
to say oh i hope you i would never you
know what i mean like
a no-brainer yeah
i agree
who the [ __ ] wants to listen to a really
jaded guarded podcast like [ __ ] let's
like be transparent and talk about it
yeah for sure so what uh where can
people get a hold of you
did you put your number on the bottom of
it
hold on
a chiron for the whole
how much of uh of your livelihood
is within the sort of parameters of
recovery versus like other
so when i got sober and i kind of got
into that world of of of
part of it being a job you know i called
my sponsor who's a private therapist and
i said lex what do you think about this
and he goes well what i'm going to tell
you is and he had at the time 13 years
over he said i'm going to tell you
most people
in the industry that are so
recovery that work on the industry side
don't stay sober right exactly what you
said he said there's a fine line there's
work and then there's your sobriety and
the moment that lying gets blurred
you'll drink again and i like adhered to
that i paid a lot of attention because i
really value my sobriety and uh
and and so i know that they're just two
worlds apart you know what i mean like
it's so i i know which means i'm to be
held accountable right um and
so
i'd say
definitely 50 50
if i could but who can gauge that sure
um so so the the stuff that you do
like help us out like with the the
business of brandon open by novak's
house yeah
novak's house yeah which is
i recreated what worked for me right
like i like you did i i went to
treatment and then i lived in a sober
house for a year because that's what my
sponsor suggested that i do because he
did it and at the time he had 13 years
so i wasn't trying to reinvent the wheel
and i followed suit and and that house
kind of taught me it taught me legit
like how to wash my clothes for the
first
month that i was in there i was washing
my clothes with uh
dishwashing detergent because i didn't
know
memory lane
and and then you know guys they're like
you can't wash your clothes with like
dishwashing detergent you need like i
just i was really disconnected from
reality and it taught me how to
integrate or merge back into the world
like as a quote unquote normal human
being and i realized the impact that had
on me and what it did for me so as i
continued to stay sober that being in
that house was like some of the best
times of my life sure like i i would go
back and do it in a heartbeat life was
very simple when i was in cerbere living
so
how long did you detox for
uh my detox was like
the eye roll that's even worse than
screaming at him he's like not when to
eat
a human
i was on detox meds for a week but i
felt like [ __ ] for probably two or three
at least
i didn't sleep right for like a couple
months i feel like a lot of people don't
want to get sober because they don't
want that they don't want the detox and
they're scared to detox
that used to be my excuse
in the beginning yeah and then i got to
a point where i think i matured i think
a lot of things aligned it all my
attempts at recovery
these seeds were planted along the way
yeah and then one day like it all just
kind of
aligned and this [ __ ] skies parted
and i walked across the [ __ ]
um
you you have a youtube channel
yeah are you pretty active with it i've
seen your [ __ ] pop up on there yeah i i
as much as i can be you do your own
editing no
okay i have a team that helps yeah
because i mean dude creating content man
that's a [ __ ] amazing livelihood it
is it so i don't really pay much
attention to it at all but i i do okay
and uh i've decided to take the money
that i make from that to just invest in
weird [ __ ] like bitcoin and wow are you
into bitcoin not enough to like let it
determine my day but you know just in
case i i it does explode and i don't
miss the boat well that just happened
kind of i know i know
thanks pal
yeah i'm [ __ ] well aware right but
you know i'd rather try and fail than
never try and wonder whatever [ __ ] it
yeah dude so um
yeah so i have i i'm so i recreated the
house that i got sober in and it's a
it's just a straight-up sober house um
and it's a men's house and there's 12
guys in it and it's not like insurance
based it's not really like treatment
industry world [ __ ] it's it's uh
it's guys that come from the streets
that like have no insurance or state
insurance
and they have to come directly from
treatment which is what i was a product
of right i didn't have like great
insurance that allowed me to go to like
a beverly hills place
and uh
i have like
people that have been generous enough to
donate you know
financially to it which then allows me
to provide scholarships and there's 12
guys in it and i
unfortunately it's full right because
there's like a need for it and i wish
that wasn't the case i wish i couldn't
like get it sure i mean there's also
like
lots of dogs in the street in peru and i
could only take one exactly yeah
that's why you're an asset dude
and and that's and and i i it created
the fire on me to like want to get more
and help more so i i acquired the house
across the street and
last week it opened and that's full and
and now on my birthday which is the 10th
i i close on the third house so by the
end of december i'll have 40 beds uh
and i provide scholarships for all the
gentlemen that come after completing 30
days of treatment to then having 30 days
of a free bed so they don't have to
worry about like where am i going to get
a job to pay the rent for you know
because when you get out of trouble it's
like so i'm creating
i'm not doing anything i'm just getting
a lot of assistance and through
a lot of different ways for people to
help so is there like a 501 c 3 like
non-profit organization people can
donate to to i looked into that and the
problem with that was if i turned it
into a 501c3 then i wouldn't own the
properties
like the
and and that's kind of although it
provides an amazing service for a
financially reasonable cost
the it's also very nice to own the homes
at the end and i don't want to not own
the homes right yeah it's kind of like
my 401k plan there's a b corp where i
think that's dual it's five
and profit i think you can do some
ancillary 501 c 3 that would just
create
money for the scholarships which isn't
tied to that
i was just told about that like last
night actually so it's something i mean
i've been uh we've just celebrated our
first year um okay so i'm not you know
i'm learning as i go um
but it's it's an amazing cause that it
brings me the most joy how much is it to
scholarship somebody for a month well
it's 180 a week so times four
i don't even know what that wow 720
yeah can you put me down for a
scholarship and one guy for the month
really yeah please that would be amazing
totally so all right that's really
really
did give give me give me two guys two
really give me two no give me two
four
all right see we got we got uh at one
point he's not gonna be jerked off to
that
he's not gonna win up me obviously no no
no no no no dude if you want to i want
to wow that uh
you know the coolest thing about that is
not only does it help the individual tax
right off because this is not a 500 c3
so we might as well just give them cash
i'll venmo you oh i'll i'll
but the coolest thing about that is not
only does the individual get the help
like the families get better too
the kids get better it's such a snowball
effect that goes so much further than
people can really comprehend yeah it's
just so magical um
but that's that's a big deal i love it
happy to do it wow all right
thank you thank you yeah yeah thank you
i mean that thank you
um is there anything that uh that you
would like to promote other than that
just that i'm [ __ ] sober
[Laughter]
i love it
that's it man [ __ ] sober call me oh
my god i love it dude i love you and i'm
so grateful that you're sober and that
you continue to inspire you getting
sober like help my mother not cry at
night because it inspired me to like
believe in me because i knew
the last time we partied together you
held me hostage in a hotel room and you
did k and wouldn't let me leave and i
got scared
and and i'm like if that you know same
thing if that guy can do it i can do it
and you inspired hope in me
so
thank you man
this was amazing scott i love you love
you too juicy oh yeah hey cheers man
thanks for providing the [ __ ] youtube
video on how to shoot up oh yeah yeah
you say bye
save somebody's life dude or killed
somebody
and there you have it ladies and
gentlemen a shockingly candid podcast
from a shockingly candid guest and here
we are man i'm not kidding about being
on this bucket list tour and taking care
of myself
yeah
i i pound liquid death i pound liquid iv
and i be pounding my sandwiches from
doordash that's all there is to it and
i'm also
truly grateful for you guys and
again i want to say this the number of
people who have told me on this bucket
list tour that they are members of the
street team
it warms my heart man and uh
i'm just stoked on everything going on
in my life right now and thank you for
being here being a part of it [ __ ] yeah